mes parents étaient des militants
associatifs par héritage
j'ai continué donc cet engagement auprès
d'une population handicapée et j'avais
15 ans quand je suis arrivé à la réunion
j'ai continué ce bénévolat alors que
j'avais deux enfants en bas âge et je
les fais à la salle saint françois
d'assise
c'est comme ça on va dire que je suis
rentré en bénévolat dans le secteur
personnages les essais dans les années
80 à croix quand j'ai commencé à la
société de gérontologie donc pierre
catteau était président que vraiment
j'ai pu travailler avec lui
au quotidien et découvrir l'amour qu'il
avait pour les personnes âgées et en
même temps ben moi de me le faire aussi
mieux comprendre ses engagements et
naturel il est il est orienté personnes
âgées par nature ces valeurs
les portes fort au avec fierté et mais
avec modestie elle a toujours été
quelqu'un qui a entraîné les autres
affaires à faire mieux pour propose pour
les personnes âgées c'est sa motivation
donc une fille formidable qu'on pourrait
dire autre chose